hello wordsmiths I hope luck is with us
today because on the high seas of
vocabulary there's no telling what word
we'll encounter
encounter it's a verb a noun too the
verb means to unexpectedly meet with
someone or something to come face to
face with something as a noun it means
much the same thing an unexpected
face-to-face meeting let's head over to
the derivation station and break this
word down into its constituent Parts n
meaning in and Contra meaning against
the the the original meaning of on
contre in French was to confront or
fight someone so you're up against
someone in their face opposed to them
let's take those word Parts n and Contra
and see what other words we can make
from them I'll give you 10 seconds
during this music break ready here we
[Music]
go
okay here are some that I came up with
there's contrast to show differences
right if I'm contrasting an apple with
an orange I'm holding one up against the
other and saying what's different
between these two
fruits entice to draw in to tempt the
the scent of freshly baked cookies
enticed you into the kitchen and
contrary right a a word meaning opposite
opposed against something if you say
you're in favor of cookies and I'm
opposed to cookies I'll say on the
contrary my friend I reject your cookie
proposal in favor of beans go on ask me
about my favorite Bean oh too late it's
good mother Stallard that's my favorite
Bean varietal I'm extremely cool but
enough of this Bean business wordsmiths
you and I have an encounter with Destiny
and our destiny is to use the word
encounter in some sentences first let's
use it as a verb on the 70th day of its
Voyage The Good Ship undertook to
encountered a giant squid in a terrible
mood nothing good ever happens to the
Good Ship under toe so they encountered
they met up with maybe they even had to
fight that giant squid or maybe she just
needed a hug look at her she's having a
bad day okay and now let's try it in
noun form it was only a brief encounter
but I think I met a merman right so the
speaker was only face Toof face with the
merman for a short time not all
encounters are conflicts can also just
be running into someone
unexpectedly like a myman for my part I
have never encountered a myr person of
any gender but if I did I would tell
them the same thing I'm telling you you
can learn anything David out